what was the group it was this group  called new ground and they asked me to  be the girl in the video I was 13 years  old and if you see the video it is  frightening that a 13 year old should be  in this video anyway it's rather you  were 13 I was let's take a look  [Music]  because that's what you are  [Applause]  that's against the law you're 13 and  they're throwing money on you so I could  get ice cream later ice cream mom like  just up having a cup of coffee she  actually was there yeah yeah yeah oh  they're throwing 20s on my daughter now  man no big deal all right well yeah it's  not spiritual mother the important thing  is you were 13 and your hand and money  is raining down on you were you even  aware of what oh yeah what was going on  video absolutely not I just thought that  they like I was worth a lot of money so  they're investing in my company